solution heaven it's hard for us to find
a time just the two of us defend this
video so we just want to say
congratulations for hitting your 1
million YouTube subscribers I know
you've been waiting for this moment for
a long time and yeah good job it and I
want to say that I've never seen anyone
who loves his job so much the last few
days when I was home I see you dancing
bouncing on the trampoline and you're
just having a lot of fun while you're
working and I've never seen anyone and
I'm very happy
[Music]
Evon sometimes we think that you're
crazy but you and you have a lot of
crazy ideas but we're still support with
your crazy ideas congratulation 1
million yay we need to celebrate this
time together
Evon my man I'm back home in Bucks
County but I just heard that you're
about to crash through 1 million
subscribers and I wanted to send you
some serious love not just to you but to
your entire team you have been an
inspiration to me too I'm short tons and
tons of your subscribers and quite
frankly you earned your million way way
back because you've contributed to the
growth of my channel and I'm sure I've
inspired people your ripple effect is
just huge man so I'm so happy that I got
a chance to meet you last year at
clammer con I am so looking forward to
seeing you again congratulations and
keep making that impact yo what's up
[ __ ] now Hoyt here and I just want to
congratulate everything on hitting 1
million subscribers here on YouTube I
woke up 4:30 every morning and I get to
the grind I don't do coffee but I gotta
have my interests so every morning to
get me in a positive mind frame to crush
the goals that I have every single day
this is by far the most watched channel
that I have here on YouTube I watch your
videos every single day whether I'm
cleaning the house doing yoga editing my
videos which takes hours but your videos
and your content this keeps me motivated
to keep on pushing through and your work
ethic is motivation in and of itself
with 4,500 videos just pushing you
definitely got it in blood by working
hard every single day blood sweat and
tears in order to get too many
subscribers so I want to congratulate
you congratulate your family
congratulate your team you definitely
own success and keep on rockin Evan
Carmichael congratulations on 1 million
subscribers that's amazing but you know
it's not really that surprising because
you are amazing your content inspires so
many to believe more and to really do
more with their lives I've appreciated
it I know millions of people around the
world have been impacted by your content
by your message and by your life but you
know what I really believe this that
your best days are still ahead of you so
keep crushing it and keep leading the
way keep inspiring us and we'll talk
soon
I'm very happy that you're a survivor
and I'm glad to be one of your 1 million
subscribers what's up Evan listen in the
words of dj khaled you smart you lawyer
you were icon
he just got a million plus subscribers
on YouTube Congrats man job well done
hey Evan its cat Harvey congratulations
on reaching a million subscribers I'm so
happy for you you definitely deserve it
all you have definitely changed my life
my business my TV show my radio show 360
degrees with your content if you guys
are not already following Evan
Carmichael he's the best you have to
watch them and make sure you tell your
friends and your family about them again
congratulations Evans cat Harvey success
nonetheless thank you
what's up Evan congratulations on
getting a million subscribers I'm super
stoked for you brother I've been
following you for a while and you're
amazing and your passion and your
dedication to this journey and believe
nation is just super impressive so I
really appreciate everything you've done
for me and everybody else through your
channel so thank you very much Evan and
congratulations for getting a million
subscribers
oh yeah congratulations Evan I am so
excited for you and so happy to be one
of your 1 million subscribers
gabriele angel here you just want to say
thank you your book your videos your
believe nation team have really had a
positive impact on my mindset so hey
Evan this is Michael Patrick from still
feel 21 I wanted to offer you a
heartfelt congrats on surpassing 1
million YouTube subscribers on your
channel while I am in all of this
accomplishment I am in no way surprised
that you were able to do this there are
few people in business and in life that
live their values each and every day
like you do thank you for the direct and
positive impact you have made on my life
and all the best to you and your entire
camp great job Evan cheers man
Congrats sir Evan we are so excited for
you no one deserves this more you know
what's really cool about this first 1
million to me is that I know that for
you it's not just about hitting a number
goal each and every one of those 1
million is a person that I know that you
genuinely care about believe in and you
truly want to see each and every one of
those 1 million people believe in
themselves and go out and impact the
world and make it a better place
you are the real deal you are amazing so
thank you for letting me be a part of
that 1 million and for believing in me
and we believe in you
hi Evan congratulations reaching your 1
million subscribers I've been following
your YouTube channel for a long time now
and I've also been one of your readers
of your new book your book your one word
I'm looking forward to your new book
that comes out in December wish you all
the best
Thanks Imran Khan grams Iman for 1
million subscribers I'm so happy for you
I hope you reach 10 million subscribers
soon and I think you should give a party
to your team today if luck for your new
book I'm really excited for your new
book 10 rules of success I hope you
become New York bestseller and Amazon
bestseller so best of luck and sending
you lots of love bye bye take care hey
Evan
it's Roger Pierce I just wanted to say
way to go on reaching a million
subscribers on YouTube and it's such an
amazing accomplishment
Evan you should know your work impacts
entrepreneurs around the world and I
know you're gonna keep going
congratulations my friend and best
wishes hello and congratulations 1
million subscribers I just wanted to say
that I knew you were gonna make it
because you are good people you know
you're a good person inside and you show
that through your team and the way you
work I had the opportunity to
collaborate with you and I'm so grateful
for that because you showed me you are
the real
so yeah you made a believer out of me
all the love from Argentina bye
congratulations seven hi Ivan it's my
coma from chart your trade calm
congratulations on hitting 1 million
subscribers that's absolutely amazing
thank you for helping me find my one
word inspire and thank you so much for
continuing to inspire me every single
day with all the great content that you
put out on your channel and in
everything else that you do truly
appreciate thank you for your inspiring
me and thank you for being a great
example to all of us
take care Congrats hi Evan it's me
Stephanie from where Stephanie reads I
want to say congrats on the 1 million
subscribers good job
and I also want to thank you for all the
hard work you put into your videos and
all everything and also how much is for
me and I also love your book and can't
wait for the next one so congrats woo hi
Evan it's Jamie drum from relaxing sleep
station wanted to say congratulations on
making it to a million subscribers and I
know really what that means to you is
that it's the potential of a million
people that you've touched and that
you've helped work through some of their
entrepreneurial or even their their
psychological issues that they've been
working through in relation to building
a better life for themselves you've made
a big impact on me and thank you very
much
Julianne 7 on reaching 1 million
subscribers I'm really really delighted
for you and I just want to say a big big
thank you to you for everything that you
have done all the inspiring content that
you put out on a daily basis your
amazing book your one word has really
had a huge impact on my life I opened my
own YouTube channel just because of all
the inspiration I got from your channel
not only - but your book has also helped
me to figure out what I wanted to do
with life and I decided to go back and
study I'm also very very grateful for
all the amazing people that I have come
in contact with through your channel and
all the collaborations and everything
these things would have ever been
possible you have changed my life for
the better and I really really
appreciate just please keep doing what
you're doing
you are amazing and I hope that you are
enjoying this milestone and I got to
give you a great big kiss laughing Oh
from Ireland have an amazing day and
thank you so much
I just wanted to say congratulations on
on your 1 million subscribers something
you don't know is that I I see I see all
the content you put out and how much you
put out it's it's insane I I and just
seeing you put out so much it really
drives me to work and I mean you
personally you you met up with me so
many times help me out so you know I
appreciate what you do and
congratulations just the beginning
because you will inspire millions of
entrepreneurs to believe Austin hey
there have been word has it you're about
to hit a million subscribers on YouTube
channel I want to say a big
congratulations hell of an
accomplishment
you definitely know how to make people
believe so keep up the good work and I
look forward to making another video for
when you hit 2 million yes both from
four-minute masters you've just hit a
million subscribers congratulations man
what an incredible journey thank you for
everything you've done not just for me
but everyone in the world with your
inspiration your motivation and your
just dedication to unlock human
potential so what's next
two million we'll see you then you're a
legend Devin I'm honored to know you
rise and believe heaven I'm a rock and I
want to congratulate you for 1 million
subscribers I want to thank you because
you have inspired me to dream and
accomplish my dreams I see your videos
on a regular basis and whenever I feel
down in my life I open your YouTube
channel and get inspired the work that
you do is extraordinary and I want to
thank you for this
always keep dreaming and I hope you
continue to believe in yourself thank
you very much
Evans so excited for you congratulations
on hitting 1 million subscribers I know
for you it's not just about a number it
really is about the lives around the
world you've been able to touch
including mine congratulations to you on
your growth all the great content that
you put out there benefits us but also
wishing you nothing but continued
blessings for yourself and for the
family looking forward to 1 million more
subscribers joining the belief nation
around the world I have an
congratulation for reaching 1 million
YouTube subscribers that is so huge man
congratulation and I'm so proud of you
let's skip it let's bake to believe
vision bigger
hey what's up Evan I just wanted to say
thank you so much for all the
inspiration and encouragement and the
consistency that you provided over the
years I wouldn't be where I'm at without
you and your channel Evan
congratulations on reaching 1 million
subscribers best of wishes from Romania
hey what's up Evan congratulations
you've hit a million subscribers that's
an awesome job like you say you're about
believing in people and you really stand
by it you stand by it not only by saying
it by but by acting on it as well so
keep doing great things and keep making
it grow I know you're only gonna get
bigger and better every time Evan
congratulations on crushing the 1
million mark I'm so happy for you and
thank you for all the videos and all the
content you put out on YouTube it's
really helped me out
thank you for your book also and I can't
wait to to grab the other one
Congrats then thanks for helping me find
my one word heart which is the adventure
into the unknown to become a better
version of myself Congrats on the 1
million subs hey Evan this is our man I
just wanted to congratulate you on your
1 million subscriber list I just wanted
to thank you for the book I actually
read the whole book and I gotta tell you
it's one of the best books that I've
read it's very detail-oriented so I
actually utilize that one word into my
own personal business so it made a huge
difference again congratulations and
keep up the good work
hey this is John D Webster I want to say
congratulations on reaching 1 million
subscribers there is no one who has
worked harder for it or is more
deserving of it as you would say much
love
hey Ron is there was good energy from
India I just want to thank you and
congratulate you for just being crossed
1 million subscriber but but I just
thought you know that you deserve move
and more and more subscriber because you
contain helping me a lot for become the
best version of myself in a daily basis
so I just want to thank you again and
again congratulate you
Steve blessed congratulations Evan I am
so proud of you you know I remember from
the very beginning when we'll use the
chat and you actually reply but now
you're just too big to get back to me
but I can't I can't say congratulations
enough and I've been there from the very
beginning and I've just been following
you the whole time and I'm just so proud
of you and I'm just so I'm kind of
emotional right now
gratulations Evan you voted hey I've
been congratulations on reaching 1
million subscribers i watch your videos
every day to get that little boost of
motivation and wisdom to get me through
the day and it's nice to see a similar
soul trying to spread the message of
self to putin development self
improvement and also getting people to
believe in themselves so congratulations
on 1 million and you deserve it and keep
the good work up from Derek RT in
England on a thank you and the team for
your videos and help me develop as a
person and growing the business
congratulations on passing 1 million
subscribers and then Congrats on
reaching a million subscribers buddy
that's awesome
here's to two million stop settling
start living
gratulations I've been on hitting 1
million YouTube subscribers
that's an amazing success thank you for
your hard work and dedication and
devotion to being now the motivational
waffle also very inspirational ask away
from someone who's one word is honest
Evan Carmichael 1 million subscribers
congratulations man the throne belongs
to the people who believe they deserve
it so get out of your own way stop
holding yourself back and go get what's
yours here's to another 10 million of
them so let's keep hustling man Evan
congratulations on 1 million subscribers
it's because of all of the awesome
things that you do to inspire other
people your one word book your top ten
videos just everything that you do is
awesome you remind people of the power
of human potential and the power of
belief so congratulations on 1 million
hey what's up Evan congratulations on
your 1 million subscriber mark I'm glad
to say that I've been part of those 1
million since gosh for years since you
were starting out so keep it going I
can't wait till you hit 2 million man
it's fun to keep collaborating with you
and good luck
hey Evan this is Anthony Mena from Avena
vlogs I just wanted to congratulate you
on passing 1 million subscribers that's
so incredible man it's been great to
work with you this year you have an
amazing channel your videos are always
helpful and inspiring to me and I look
forward to working with you again in the
future so congratulations on the 1
million subs and here's to the next
million my friend congratulations Evan
this is your boy Jason Schemmel from the
GSD chat saying congrats on hitting 1
million YouTube subscribers man that's
fantastic I absolutely love your top 10
videos they're highly inspirational and
motivational and you can see that they
positively make an impact on people's
lives RIT in the comments on all of your
videos man so keep up the great work
I know your word is believed I believe
in you keep it up and I look forward to
your next video man believe hey Evan I
am so happy for you congratulations what
an amazing milestone you've achieved and
you deserve every single bit of it I
know how hard you've worked I've been so
honored to be a part of your journey and
to watched your improvement on your
and what's so cool is you've let that up
there for all of us so we could see
where you've come from and so that we
could believe in ourselves too that we
could improve just as much as you have
and watch your dedication and what's so
cool even more cool is that you have
done all of this because you have had a
mission to help others believe and so
you've helped us us youtubers us
entrepreneurs basically on your channel
you've been helping us all along while
you've been accomplishing this a major
goal so I am so happy for you and I'm so
appreciative to everything you've done
for me as a youtuber as an entrepreneur
someone who's been a part of your team
I'm I just couldn't be more pleased way
to go keep on believe it thanks so much
and Congrats hey Evan its generating
entrepreneurs comm just wanted to tell
you congratulations on achieving your 1
million subscriber yes Evan that's
definitely such a huge accomplishment
congratulations and we wish you the best
in your further success we're very proud
of you Evan keep up the hard work yes
make sure you celebrate oh my god just
want to say congratulations for reaching
over a million subscribers on your
YouTube channel keep believing and
making us proud hi Evan
I'm Lena from Denmark and I've been
following you on YouTube for about two
years
a friending of mine told me your name
and about your work on YouTube and I'm
grateful for have been able to follow
you for these years you gave me a lot of
hope and belief and I also want to thank
you for the great book that I read I
just want to say thank you for your good
YouTube channel and I wish you all the
best
Evan I just want to say congrats on
hitting the 1 million that's a big deal
a very big deal you deserve it and
continue to believe take care hey guys
it's Owen video and I wanted to say
congratulations Evan Carmichael on
subscribers you know when I was sick
with cancer I would wake up every
morning and I would get motivated and
pumped up by watching your videos thank
you for what you do you've helped me to
believe hey Evan
just wanted to tell you congratulations
you've done very good work
I appreciate every video that you send
out I'm get a chance to watch all of
them but when I do they are really
inspiring to me I try to watch it every
morning when I can your book was amazing
even on that entrepreneur I'm not
thinking about as of now right now it
still helped you still helping me
improve my life thank you we appreciate
you okay
keep it going hey everyone hey Z here
Evan I want to congratulate you and the
Evan Carmichael channel on reaching that
1 million subscribers who didn't see
that one coming right you were on your
way there we all knew it
hey I just want you to know I do I start
my day every day with the morning
espresso I mean not to mention
throughout the day the collaboration of
mental geniuses and information that
you've collaborated together and put out
for us is amazing it's helped me over
the last couple of years I've had a
really tough time and a lot of it's been
exactly the motivation that I need I
appreciate it so much you must have had
the most amazing parents in the whole
wide world to have installed the kind of
information that they have into you than
to create the kind of person that's
willing and wants to come out and share
it with the rest of us can't help you
for it you know I wish you the best
always
you're one word belief I using it
everyday too and I hope to get to see
you stand in there with the best of them
one day I know you will right next to
Warren Buffett Tony Robbins Jeff Peebles
Macy's Day you never know you never know
it's coming Evan Evan Carmichael channel
everyone involved congratulations we
have most deserved 1 million subscribers
plus plus plus and beyond that I've ever
seen you guys are the best thank you so
much
hello Evan Carmichael this is litrenta
George here congratulations on hitting
your mouth stone 1 million subscribers
you rot believe makes this on fire I'm
so happy for you thank you so much for
your platform please continue to pour
all that great content into us
entrepreneurs across the world we love
you we're happy to be a part of your
life and this journey thank you so much
[Music]
that is amazing
I'm super proud of you you are a giant
inspiration to me and all the other
million people that follow you on
YouTube really proud of you buddy
you totally deserve the success way to
go congratulations congratulations Evan
1 million subscribers Wow you are what
you preach in just a few more million
you will have a billion entrepreneurs on
your channel congratulations
hey Evan congratulations I'm so happy
for you that you reach the million
subscribers is just one small step to
making an impact on a billion people so
thank you for being in my life thank you
for being a great mentor you've taught
me so many things the one of things you
taught me is right here it's in the
sticky notes it says better three hours
too soon than a minute too late William
Shakespeare I mean the list goes on how
many things I learn from you I just want
to say thank you you're an incredible
force hey this was for you just want to
say thank you for your hard work
my name is will Katie two times your
book I want word well your Lord it's a
great book and I also like a channel all
the things you do every morning things
brush those and all the other messages
using that to change my life and
hopefully next time I see you see how
successful I've become later
congratulations Evan on your 1 million
subscribers well done you're on fire
hello even I just wanted to take this
time to congratulate you on milestone
that you've just reached we're so
excited with you and we're so happy for
you thank you for making
entrepreneurship such an reachable and
possible thing for everyone thank you
for inspiring belief into us keep
inspiring